welcome back
welcome back we're on problem number 15.
and i tried it as best that i can to
draw it and they're pretty much saying
that they're saying that well i'll read
it doug's biology experiment involving
timing 12 hamsters in a maze each
hamster received at least one practice
before being timed the scatter plot
above shows the time each hamster took
to complete the maze and the
corresponding number of practices that
each hamster received
based on the data which of the following
functions best models the relationship
between t
between t the number of seconds to
complete the maze
so number of seconds
number of seconds
this is the t-axis
and p the number of practices this is p
number of practices so we want to find
t as a function of p
right
so t is a function of p so one it looks
like our time didn't the hamsters didn't
learn much when they got practice you
know no matter how much practice they
got the hamsters looks like you know
they roughly took about the same amount
of time
and we could kind of we could try to
draw a line here that fits this curve
you know maybe it would look something
like this
i don't know something like that
right i mean it's not going to be you
know you could try to be cute and try to
draw something maybe with a little bit
of a slope or anything but i mean really
this looks like a flat line when you
look at it
so what would be the equation of that
line well the equation of that line
that'd be like 45 or 44 or something
so if you said t of p is equal to and
actually they have a choice that looks
just like that tfp is equal to 44.
t of p is equal to 44. no matter how
many practices the mice got regardless
of how many they on average take roughly
44 seconds so practice doesn't really
help mice much as opposed to
students preparing for the sat and all
the other ones don't make any sense i
mean t if p equals p that would be that
would be something like this choice a is
something like that that has no sense um
oh no sorry choice a is our answer t
choice b looks something like that
choice
c 44 b that'll be even a super steep
that's that makes no sense p over 44
that's going to be like a
a really shallow graph and then you
could have p plus 44 that would start
here and then have a slope of one so it
would look like that so none of the
other ones are even close so it's
definitely choice a t of p is equal to
44.
last problem
problem and i'll do a
new color problem 60 oh my god problem
16.
and they drew this thing
so we have a big square
and then we have
square like
no let me
it's right there okay so i have a square
like that
actually i should just use a line tool
that would be better
square like that
and then i have
this is okay
a square like
that roughly
not perfectly drawn because these three
squares look the same and they tell us
they're the same they tell us that this
is w
this is l w
w w
l
the pattern shown above is composed of
rectangles
this pattern is used repeatedly to
completely cover a rectangular region 12
units long and 11 units wide so they're
covering a region
that's 12
12 l long
and
10 l wide 10 l wide so this is like a
you know a thumbnail of the floor
how many rectangles of dimension
l
by w are needed
how many rectangles of dimension l by w
are needed
okay well when they say how many
rectangles of dimension l by w that's
just what each of these rectangles that
they drew here right because all of
these have dimensions l by w l by w
l by w l by w l by w right so if we
could figure out just how many of these
you know this pattern has one two three
four five of those on it right
so if we could just figure out how many
of this pattern
would fit onto this
then we are
we're done right
so how can we how can we figure that out
so on something
do we know a relationship
between l and w well sure
we see here that two l's are the same
thing as three w's we know that
two l is equal to
three
w's
and since we all our dimensions are
given in l let's solve for w and
substitute so
let's say that w is equal to just divide
both sides by three
w is equal to two thirds l
right
all i said is you know 2l is the same
thing as 3w and i divided by 3. so w is
equal to
2 3 l
so can we represent the the height
and the width of this rectangle now in
terms of only l's well sure what's the
height
what's the uh
the length of this rectangle well the
length is just 2l right l plus l that's
the length and what's the width
well w is what it's 2 3 l
two thirds l plus l
so what's the width of this rectangle
what's two thirds of something plus
one whole of that something or two
thirds plus three thirds so the width is
five thirds
l
right so each of these rectangles
each of these rectangles is five thirds
l
by
two l
so how many of these rectangles are we
going to have to
put onto this floor
how many total well going in this
dimension
they're 2l they're they have a length of
2l so if we want to if we have to
if they're 2l each then we're going to
need six of them right we're going to
need 6 in this direction right because
we're going to go a total distance of
12l and they're 2l each so they're going
to be 6 in that direction and how many
are we going to need in this direction
well we have to go total distance of 10
l
and the width of each of them is 5 3 l
right so what's 10 divided by 5 3 so the
l's cancel out so 10 divided by 5 thirds
the same thing is 10 times three-fifths
and then that just equals six so we're
going to need six rectangles in this
direction as well so how many total
rectangles are we're going to need well
6 times 6
is equal to 36 total rectangles
and then how many of these smaller
rectangles are in each of the we'll need
36 of this pattern and then how many of
the rectangles are in that pattern well
we counted there's five
so we're going to need five times 36
total of these you know these smaller
rectangles
so 5 times 36
is what 150 plus 30. it's 180.
we will need a 180 of these smaller
rectangles so that is choice e and we
are done with this uh
test three
i'll see you in test four